if you are great at connecting if you
love going to events and you love
introducing yourself and that's you then
you should go all in on it understand
that there are people whose job it is at
these big companies to find influencers
to find people have an audience
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want to help
you find it embrace it and make a
difference using it so to help you on
your journey today I'm gonna talk about
the seven ways that you can make more
money from advertising and brand deals
enjoy so this video is brought to you by
the workshop that I'm doing in May I'm
teaching people how to make money build
a business off of being a thought leader
and basically do what I do do what I do
before your business for your industry
and I'm taking up to 15 people to be
able to do it walk through steal my
playbook work with you hands-on
one-on-one we are 80 percent sold out we
have three more spots left if anybody
wants to join the link is in the
description so when the questions that
get asked a lot by people who are trying
to build a brand is how do I start
making some money from this how do I get
ad deals how do I get sponsorship deals
how do I get brains to pay attention to
me and start actually turning what I
have in here into money to support
myself and build an empire so today I'm
going to talk to you about these seven
different ways that I have used and that
you can to to make money from
advertising and brand deals
[Music]
way number one is have a hyper targeted
niche if you have a wide audience if
your audience is all over the place from
a demographic perspective
men women geography all sorts of
different industries it's really hard to
start getting brand deals and
advertising deals and get paid a lot of
money for doing it what they want to see
is access to a specific market and so
you don't need to have a massive
audience people to start making good
advertising and brand deals what you
need to do is have a hyper targeted
audience so as an example for my
audience its entrepreneurs it's
entrepreneurs and wannabe entrepreneurs
if you have no interest in starting the
business you're probably not going to be
a fantastic fit for a lot of the content
on my channel and so a lot of the people
who want to work with me are the ones
who want to sell to entrepreneurs I got
my first brand deal when I had thirty or
forty thousand subscribers on YouTube
and so when the first brand deal kind of
reached out to me and said hey we want
to work together I was not trying to get
brand deals it was not part of my
ambition they reached out to me
understand that there are people whose
job it is at these big companies to find
influencers to find people have an
audience and I had thirty forty thousand
subscribers I don't know how many years
ago that was like it's just so much
easier now if I had thirty to forty
thousand subscribers now I would have
probably got my first brand deal much
earlier there's so many more brands
coming into the scene now they want to
know who the up-and-coming people are
and so you don't need to have a massive
audience you don't need to have millions
of people following you what you need to
do is have a trusted relationship with a
hyper targeted niche and so if you're
trying to be everything to all people
you will lose if you can say this is Who
I am serving this is where I can be the
best at and provide so much value to my
audience whether that blows up later on
that's okay but at the beginning hyper
hyper hyper targeted if you have a
dedicated loyal audience of hyper
targeted people you can start charging a
lot more for advertising and you start
attracting brand deals to your business
[Music]
way number two is look at money topics
this is super important especially in
the advertising space you have two ways
ago you either go for quantity where
you're trying to get as many eyeballs on
something as possible the other side of
the equation is how much of people
paying per eyeball so not every eyeball
is the same not every view counts are
the same a lot of Nicias can be really
hard to make money in versus other
niches and so what you want to do is
figure out how much can you make in your
niche and what are some of the money
keywords or topics that advertisers will
spend money with you on so as an example
recipes is a really tough one
recipes there's so many people who are
making recipes there's millions of views
on some of these videos but it's hard to
make a living in recipes and cooking
videos a lot of people have tons of
subscribers and are still barely getting
by themselves because there aren't a lot
of advertisers who are advertising and
recipe videos yet whereas something like
entrepreneurship there's a lot more
advertisers as businesses in they're
competing so you don't even need as big
an audience to make money I have a team
of eight people working on my YouTube
side with those other channels that are
my size are bigger and it's still just
one person doing everything because they
can't afford to bring on a team and so
one quick way to figure out how much
money there is in a niche is to go use
the Google AdWords tool it's free it's
set up for advertisers you can type in
whatever keyword that relates to your
industry and it'll show you for the
broad terms how much people are spending
on it and it'll also show you for the
more specific terms and what you want to
start to do is look at can you
authentically talk about some of these
topics so you know as an example
everything in entrepreneurship is going
to be paid more than other topics and
recipes for example but if I used free
as an example in the video title as a
topic it wouldn't get as much revenue
because advertisers don't want to
advertise on things that we're free
right it's the wrong target market I
could go the other way though and go
with super high paying keywords if I
talked about credit cards or insurance
or legal matters I wouldn't get as many
views on those videos because you guys
don't really care that much about it but
I would get paid a lot for each of those
views that I got on there
the challenge for me is I've never
really made decisions based off of money
I've really never really tried to target
too many of those keywords and I don't
really have a lot to say about credit
cards or insurance or legal matters I
find it just as boring and uninteresting
as you do probably so that's the key
difference I think you can use the
keyword tool to help direct some of your
content to give you a sense of where
advertisers are willing to spend money
and if you're thinking about this topic
or this topic or this topic you have a
couple options
daki be a great resource to help you
identify a business case to make content
around it but if you're only making
content to try to hit those money
keywords it's probably not going to hit
because you're not passionate about that
topic so don't use that as the only
decision-making tool for you but it can
really help you figure out which content
you might want to plan around to make
more money when number three is to just
make more content you need to be
prolific you need to be the expert you
need to have tons and tons and tons of
content in your space if you want to
attract advertisers you want to attract
brands if you're making one one video a
month if you're posting once to
Instagram a week it's not gonna be
enough the way one that the algorithms
work for all of these platforms it
always rewards recency and relevancy so
relevancy back to point number one we
have a hyper targeted niche but recency
is that you have content constantly
coming up and so you may not be able to
do the same type of content multiple
times per week or multiple times per day
but that's where we have different
series different themes different ideas
I have a top 10 5 times a week I have an
espresso out five times a week I have a
mentor me I have a seven ways having a
different series can help shake up your
content a little bit still provide a lot
of value to your audience but this will
help you one develop a name inside your
industry if you want to get paid the
most amount of money if you want to
attract brands to you you should be a
known quantity in your field I am NOT a
household name I walk down the street
and it might get stopped a couple times
but most people in my city in the world
they don't know me but in the world of
entrepreneurship I'm pretty well known I
have a pretty good footprint if you are
an entrepreneur and you've watched any
YouTube videos you've probably come
across some of my con
and that's what you need for your niche
for your industry that you may not be a
celebrity in mainstream mainstream
America a mainstream world but in your
niche people know who you are and that
counts by creating consistent content so
up your content it also helps with
advertising because the more views
you're getting the more you're gonna get
paid and so I would have a goal to
double your content by the end of the
year
whatever your output ratio is now try to
double it by the end of the year so if
you're making one YouTube video a week
ultimately I want your goal to get to
one a day but that may not be feasible
with your current resources your current
level your current investment and that's
okay don't blow your brains out don't go
crazy and now decide you have to go
daily that can be your ultimate ambition
what you're working towards but if you
can get to what in the year you know two
videos a week or three videos a week
right you're slowly up in that cap as
you start making more money you can put
it back into your business and make more
investments but you need to be producing
more content YouTube you want to get to
at least one video a day I would say two
or three which is where I'm at but I say
that it scares people away so don't
worry about that yet work to getting one
because already that's that causes a
heart attack to some people Instagram
Twitter I'd be looking at least three
times a day at least I've been putting
out content consistently regularly
high-impact stuff that means something
to you you can even go higher on Twitter
twitter is the the easiest to pump out
tons of content on LinkedIn I'd be at
least multiple times per week and then
understanding the different the
different networks and where you're
gonna play don't try to play everywhere
all at once like the content has to be
good firing up a video a day on YouTube
is not going to help you if the video
sucks and I think a lot of people they
try to go YouTube and Instagram and
Pinterest and snapchat and everything
all at once and the net effect is you're
creating a lot of output but it's all
garbage until it's not gonna help you
get a lot of eyeballs or brand deals or
advertising on you it still has to be
quality it's make more content with
quality being a given right and so
that's where the goal is to get to one
add a one video day three posts a day
but you're not there yet and so you just
build a plan to really get there but
you're a [ __ ]
if you want to be the game-changing
entrepreneur thought leader making tons
of money off of advertising and brand
deals then you need to think I need to
up my content game weight number four is
have sample content it's sometimes hard
for brands to want to be the first to
partner up with somebody a lot of brands
are not very risk tolerant they want to
see that's been done before they want to
see that you work with brands before
they want to see examples of campaigns
and how you've helped and so if this is
part of your path of what you're trying
to do I would try to start working with
a brand as soon as possible I would look
at anybody that who you have a
relationship with you're using their
products or services you have a contact
somewhere you met them at a trade show
anything even if it's just not part of
their campaign at all just a tribute
like you're talking about a program that
you use or a tool or something that
you've bought before and you make a
sample video you make a sample video of
what it could look like of how working
with you as a brand could look like and
what that does is it one tweaks people
to oh this person does brand deals oh
this person might be somebody that we
could work with for our company and - it
also just starts giving case studies so
that when people are checking on your
channel or thinking about working with
influencers they pick you over somebody
else because you already have a body of
work and so if you haven't been
attracting any brand deals yet I'd be
looking at how do once a month create
some kind of content wherever your your
network is known whether it's YouTube or
Instagram or whatever it is at least
once a month doing a sample branded
content
ideally working with a brand even if
you're not getting paid even if they're
just gonna share it with their audience
and as you keep adding value you'll be
able to charge more and get paid and
keep doing it but if you can't even
manage that a free one then do it as a
tribute where they don't even know that
it's happening but you're making a video
or post or a story about something
because you love using it and you feel
that it's value for the audiences at the
end of the day still has to bring value
to your audience also be something that
they care about and the message you have
is authentic for them but showing some
samples can go a long way to giving you
the credibility I'll be able to do
their brain feels weight number five is
look at trending topics a great way to
be able to attract more eyeballs get
more notoriety get more well-known in
your industry is look at what is
trending this is something that I don't
actually do a ton of I prefer doing
evergreen content and that evergreen
content stuff that lives forever like
evergreen tree the the leaves don't fall
off in the winter I love that content I
love the fact that what I make here
today is still gonna be relevant in two
three years the top tens are still
relevant 10-15 years the advice is still
for the most part helpful I like that
but it's building a longer-term game if
you could hook on to a trend something
that's happening that's current it's a
quick way to spike the interest level in
the content that you are making so two
ways to do it one look at what's
happening in your industry what's the
hot trend what are people talking about
and then you give your perspective
you're the expert you have thoughts you
have powerful opinions what do you think
about it what is your take on it where
is it going to go and share that with
your audience and to the other way to do
it is you look at trends that are
happening outside your industry and you
make it relevant to your industry so
Trump wins the US election how does that
impact your industry something happens
else in the world the currency is
falling all over the place like some big
world event is happening how does that
impact what's going on in your industry
so you become that expert that thought
leader now doc type of content likely
won't have staying power lasting power
people may not care what you thought
about Trump winning the election they
may look back on it and say hey did you
did it come right or not you know that
your predictions happen or not but it
does provide you a window of time to be
able to really propel yourself forward
because you are commentating on what is
hot what is trending what is current
right now and it's valuable it's
valuable advice to the people in the
industry so that they can make important
decisions
[Music]
way number six is collab as an expert so
one of the best ways to grow an audience
is to find people who already have your
audience and find a way to work with
them and so what I first did on YouTube
was I looked at people who I was already
looking up to learning from I looked at
Derral Eve's and looked at Tim Schmoyer
I was trying to build my YouTube channel
and these guys were putting out so much
great content and how to build a YouTube
channel and because I was already part
of their community I had a good vibe for
the type of content they were looking
for and I reached out to both of them
and I said hey I live in Carmichael I'm
a fan of your channel I've been come
within some of your videos here's what I
do I think I could be an expert and
provide an opinion on some of your
content and bring more value to your
audience
so for Derral Eve's he's about how to
rank YouTube videos but also how to
build a business around it and I pitched
him making an idea on public speaking
how do you get public speaking gigs off
of YouTube Darryl said I love that
that's a great idea and so he did an
interview with me and we did that
collaboration and he helped promote my
channel Tim I've done multiple
collaborations with we did how do I find
so many different ideas to talk about
forward my youtube channel because we're
doing so many videos a day where people
sometimes struggle to do one a week how
do you come up with ideas and a bunch of
other ones I don't even remember them
right now but they came because I am a
fan of theirs I'm in their community I
know what they like and when I reached
out it was with intent with thought you
can do it cold you could do what
channels you've never heard of but the
likelihood of you getting a yes is
really low and so what I'd be looking at
for collaborations is think about who
you already follow who is a little bit
ahead of you you know you may not be
able to get somebody who has 3 million
subscribers on their channel if you are
just starting off with a hundred you
might if you really know them you might
if you know that they have this big
problem you know they know they have a
problem with figuring out the next
mascara they should use and you are a
mascara expert right like you might be
able to do it but chances are you need
to hit just a little bit above your
weight class if it's somebody below you
it probably won't give you that much
value apart from it's just fun to do
I've done clouds with lots of different
youtubers who
have smaller audiences and me it's just
because I like doing it just because
it's fun more than I'm hoping to grow my
channel but if you're looking at how do
I get advertising how do I get brand
deals how do we get more exposure right
we're trying to get new subscribers to
come and find us and watch our videos
watch our content subscribe to what
we're doing that's gonna come from doing
collaborations that people who have a
bigger audience than you so just find in
a way that you can bring value to people
who have bigger audiences the same
audience just more of them and their
recommendation feeds into you getting
more subscribers more of a following
more views on the stuff that you're
making and way number seven to get brand
deals in advertising is to do outreach
this is my least favorite way I much
prefer trying to build up a marketing
machine as opposed to a sales machine
but I think it really just depends on
what your strengths are so the sales
machine is your calling up people your
getting on the phone your hitting them
up on email you're following them on
social you're going to all the trade
shows and you're getting to know who are
the brains who are the brains that are
trying to advertise to this market that
I'm able to do an ad deal with I might
be able to do some kind of brand
awareness campaign with and you might
make a great connection at a local event
they know you they like you you form a
relationship they want to sponsor one of
your videos that can happen for a lot of
people if you are great at connecting if
you love going to events and you love
introducing yourself and you love
networking meetings and all that kind of
stuff that's you then you should go all
in on it
load up whatever YouTube videos and
whatever magazine is in your industry
and whatever events are happening
whatever conferences and just look at
who the sponsors are if it was
entrepreneurship for example pull up
entrepreneur magazine ink magazine flip
through it who are the advertisers look
at whatever entrepreneur conferences are
happening look who's sponsoring these
are the people who are trying to get in
front of entrepreneurs those are going
to be your target clients go find them
connect with them say hi introduce
yourself make a connection and get some
deals happening that is not my strength
I much rather spend my time building a
marketing machine so that I attract
magnets for the people who want to do
brand deals with me so I have very
rarely had success with doing outreach
to people I much prefer to spend my time
creating better content building up a
ton of noise in my industry my business
model is essentially kick up as much
dust as much noise as possible in my
industry that people then notice and so
it's really important is the sales model
can work the direct outreach model can
work but it comes down to self-awareness
to understand for you what is your
preference where do you shine because if
you try to do something that you're not
good at and you don't want to get good
at and is not your passion you're gonna
lose and if you lean in heavily on the
thing that you are great at and you want
to become world-class at that's how
you're gonna win so for me it's
marketing for you might be marketing few
might be sales but direct outreach is a
possibility if you love doing it so the
my seven ways on how to make money from
advertising and brand deals I would love
to know what you think I would love to
know what was your favorite one that
you're going to start applying to your
business if there's an 8 9 10 that you
want to add to the list leave it down
the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is
much love I'll see you soon the most
important word ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you up or that would be
like a little beacon hey believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details